l'actualité en france air france en
bourse 20 % au maximum du capital sera
sur le marché
une autre partie sera proposé aux
pilotes en échange de baisses de
salaires ce qui fait grincer des dents
et de nombreux syndicats bataille contre
cette privatisation partielle
lionel que tu benoît aberrant ce n'est
pas une surprise l'état restera
majoritaire dominique strauss-kahn et
jean-claude gayssot ont annoncé
aujourd'hui que la part de l'état dans
le capital d'air france devrait passer à
67 % à la fin de l'année puis à 53 pour
cent quatre-vingt-dix-neuf au programme
du projet de privatisation partielle de
la compagnie 10% du capital devrait en
effet être réservée aux pilotes
en échange ceux-ci devront consentir une
baisse progressive de leurs salaires de
15% sur trois ans aujourd'hui
l'entreprise et la direction de
l'entreprise est obligée de recourir à
un décret pour contraindre une partie de
son personnel les pilotes à souscrire au
capital de l'entreprise
c'est un aveu d'échec car de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit d'être capable de
faire adhérer son personnel à un projet
fair avéré ne pas dire contraindre outre
ces 10% pour les pilotes
environ 20% du capital d'air france
devra être introduit en bourse dont 15%
pour le personnel un personnel inquiet
pour la cgt le gouvernement se dirige
dans la mauvaise direction
céline privatisations et une
privatisation qui est appelé comme chez
renault à se faire complètement
donc on est contre en engageant ce
processus d'autant qu'il ne se fera pas
avec tous les personnels c'est à dire
que parallèlement un certain nombre de
secteurs doivent être externalisés
finalisé et que demain il y aura des
personnels qui sont peut-être
actionnaires d'air france mais qui ne
seront plus employé par la france cette
privatisation partielle devrait faire
rentrer entre 20 et 27 milliards de
francs dans les caisses de l'état mais
la mise sur le marché des titres de la
compagnie saura-t-elle bien accueillis
des arguments plaident en sa faveur
le transporteur français a annoncé un
bénéfice de 1,7 milliard de francs pour
le premier semestre 97 98